أحد المراسلين الدوليين القلائل
الذين كانوا في بغداد لحظة
سقوط تلك الغارات الجوية كانت الأميرة
الأردنية ريم العلي وهي صديقة وزميلة سابقة
كانت مراسلة سي إن إن في
بغداد أمضت سنوات في العيش
والمراسلة من داخل العراق أه قبل
بدء الغزو أنا  تحدثت معها سابقًا
عن تأملاتها في هذه اللحظة من
الزمن، بدأت بسؤالها عما إذا كان الأمر
واضحًا قبل لحظة الصدمة والرهبة تلك،
إذا كانت الحرب وشيكة،
أعتقد أنه كان هناك أم
أنها لم تكن واضحة جدًا بالطبع في
الماضي، ربما يمكنك ذلك  أعتقد جيدًا أنه كان
من الواضح أن ذلك سيحدث
ربما عندما كنا على الأرض
لم يكن الأمر واضحًا لأنك تعلم بيكي أننا كنا
نتابع المفتشين حقًا وكان هذا
شيئًا
مثيرًا للاهتمام للغاية
وأعتقد
أن العراقيين مروا به بالفعل  سمحت
خطوة نادرة من جانب الحكومة
للصحفيين بمتابعة
المفتشين في كل مكان تمامًا، ليس
هذا فحسب، بل سيتأكدون حرفيًا من
أنك تعلم أنه لم يكن هناك
تفتيش واحد لم نعرفه، لقد
عبرنا البلاد، لقد
عبرنا البلاد  بالسيارة بطائرة
هليكوبتر على تلك المروحيات القديمة التي
لم تخضع للعقوبات والتي لم تتم
صيانتها لسنوات بسبب
العقوبات،
وقمنا حرفيًا بجولة في جميع أنحاء
البلاد مع المفتشين يتحدثون إلى
المفتشين طوال الوقت وهكذا
كان هناك  أيضًا هذا غريب جدًا، لقد
شعرنا أننا كنا في هذا العالم الغريب حيث
كنا مع المفتشين ولم يكن هناك
شيء مما
رأيناه وما أخبرنا به المفتشون،
وبالطبع كنا في حيرة شديدة
بشأن الضوضاء التي كانت  صنعت خارج
العراق وهو ما لم يكن موجودا
واليقين الذي كان هناك وفقا
لبعض الناس خارج أسلحة
الدمار الشامل، وبالتالي فإن ذلك برر
الاستعداد للحرب لذلك
فكرنا جيدا إذا أعطى المفتشون
شهادة صحية نظيفة ثم  لماذا يجب أن
يكون هناك دائمًا ذلك
الشك الذي وضعته
الحكومة العراقية وبعد ذلك أصبح واضحًا جدًا
بالنسبة لنا نحن الموجودين على الأرض بيكي
لأن السؤال الكبير كان إذا
لم تكن هناك أسلحة دمار شامل لماذا لا تكون
الحكومة العراقية كذلك؟  أليس صدام حسين
يقول بوضوح شديد أنه لا توجد
أسلحة دمار شامل؟
وبالطبع بالنسبة لأولئك منا على الأرض،
أصبح الأمر واضحًا للغاية، فأنت لا تقول ذلك
بعد أن تخرج من حرب استمرت تسع سنوات
مع إيران.
أم وبعد ما حدث في العراق وأصبح
لديك جارة كبيرة
وقوية مثل إيران وفي الواقع أه
هذا كان بالطبع واضحًا جدًا وكان هذا هو
السبب الرئيسي أه لا أحد
يريد أن يقول أه قوة مجاورة
الإمبراطور ليس لديه  الملابس لذلك كان عليهم
الاحتفاظ بها، وأعتقد أنه كان عليهم الاحتفاظ
بهذا القدر من
الضبابية حولها، وأعتقد أنه ربما كان
يناير من عام 2003 يبدو لي أنه
كان لا مفر منه، ولم أغادر العراق على ما
أعتقد منذ سبتمبر من عام 2002.
الكثير من الوقت وأنت تعرف أنك
تتعرف على الأشخاص الذين
يأتون إليك ليسألوك ليس فقط متى
ستبدأ الحرب العالمية
ويتوقعون منك أن تعرف هل ستكون
حربًا سريعة، هل ستكون كما تعلم وبالطبع كان لدى
الجميع ما يريدون  فكرتنا الخاصة عما
سيحدث، أعتقد أننا كنا
نعرف إلى حد كبير أنه كان هناك إعلان صدر
في 19 مارس، وكان من
الواضح أن هذا كان وشيكًا. ماذا تتذكر
عن
تلك الليلة في الصباح الباكر
عندما بدأ القصف
؟  التقينا جميعًا في الغرفة
التي كانت تتمتع بإطلالة أفضل
لنكون قادرين على رؤية ما كان يحدث والقدرة
على الإبلاغ
ومن الغريب أن
لدي تلك الصورة بوضوح شديد في ذهني
بيكي وكلما كنت  شاهده على شاشة التلفزيون، إنه
نوع من إعادة الحياة التي
تعرف أن قلبك يتوقف للحظة،
ويعيدها في كل
مرة أرى فيها ذلك على التلفزيون حتى لو كان
في فيلم، فأنت تسترجع تلك
اللحظة في كل مرة  أعلم أنه يمكنك رؤية
بغداد وأنت تنظر إلى ذلك مع
الضوء والقصف والصوت
معتقدًا أنك تعلم أنني آمن
لأنه يمكنك رؤية ما يحدث هناك
ولكن هناك أشخاص أعرفهم
هناك وهل هم كذلك  آمن
وما يحدث لهم، قضيت الكثير
من الوقت هناك كما قلت، أنت تعلم أنني عشت هناك وعشت هناك، أعني أنني
عشت مع
الناس وبالطبع كنت أعرف عن
قصص حياتهم وكانوا يتذكرون في كثير من
الأحيان وهم  سيتحدثون عن
أنهم مروا بحرب إيران والعراق
كانوا يتحدثون عن أنهم
مروا بذلك وإلا حرب 91
بعد غزو الكويت عندما تعرف
أه الحرب الأمريكية الأخرى عام 1991 ضد العراق
أم وهنا الأشخاص الذين
مروا بكل شيء  الذين كانوا يستعدون الآن
لخوض حرب أخرى، كان هناك
عراق مختلف، كان هناك عراق
صدام حسين وحكومته، وكان هناك
العراق الذي شوهد من الخارج
ولكن كان هناك العراق الذي رأيناه
من خلال الشعب العراقي
الذي كان في العراق.  كما تعلمون،
الحياة اليومية مليئة بالتحديات بسبب
العقوبات، لقد كانت صعبة لأنه كانت هناك
حرب عليهم قريبًا ولم يكن لديهم مكان
يختبئون فيه، كان بإمكاننا
المغادرة متى أردنا، وفي نهاية
اليوم تم طردنا، لذلك كان الأمر كذلك بالنسبة لنا.
لا
تعلم هنا أو هناك ولكننا كنا
نعلم أنه في نهاية اليوم كانت لدينا
خيارات لم تكن متاحة لهم
وأعتقد أن هذا
ربما هو ما جعل المغادرة صعبة للغاية
لأننا شعرنا أنه من
مسؤوليتنا أيضًا أن نغادر  تسليط الضوء
على ما كان يحدث لهؤلاء
الأشخاص أنفسهم خلال الحرب